un françois cocq et les cofondateurs de
l'association corona victimes essayiste
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france comment vous
réagissiez à l'ouverture de cette
enquête préliminaire du parquet de paris
donc sur la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire par les autorités écoutez ce
n'est jamais qu'un début il faut bien
commencer quelque part
vous savez dans ce pays malheureusement
le chef de l'état et bénéficie d'une
immunité pénale pendant l'exercice de
son mandat
de la même manière les ministres
l'ensemble du gouvernement dont doit
être traité par la cour de justice de la
république donc on sait que le temps
pour traiter une affaire est un temps
qui est extrêmement long et qui ne
permet donc pas d'agir sur le sur le
présent donc aujourd'hui ce sont les
plaintes pénales qui vont commencer à
être traité je note qu'elles ont été
regroupées je m'interroge sur le souhait
et la volonté qui est celle du procureur
pour avoir fait pour avoir fait cela et
j'espère que c'est plainte aboutiront le
plus rapidement possible et que la
lumière sera faite parce que vous le
savez il ya une énorme colère qui s'est
exprimée ces dernières semaines
et c est ces derniers mois il ya une
volonté populaire de
de justice que des comptes soient rendus
et les comptes politiques qui ne peuvent
pas être rendu aujourd'hui
et bien finalement on retombe sur celles
et ceux qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
différentes institutions autant au
ministère du travail au sein de santé
publique france où seuls ceux qui sont
aux responsables notamment à monsieur
tout le monde dit explicitement visé par
un certain nombre de ses planques
on sait que fayette des rumeurs de
mouvements au sein du gouvernement
est-ce que ça évidemment ça peut jouer
en faveur de cette enquête préliminaire
sur ces conclusions que les gens partout
reste en place peu importe les
responsabilités devront être établies et
celles et ceux qui ont fauté dont
devront être punis ils le seront
pénalement pour celles et ceux j'espère
qu'ils sont visés aujourd'hui encore que
je j'ai noté que le communiqué de
monsieur rémy et c'est le procureur de
bari s'engage sur une voie un petit peu
dangereuse le procureur de paris dit
dans son communiqué que s'ils étaient
adéquats seront très probablement des
fois que non intentionnel je ne suis pas
d'accord avec cela voyez monsieur
salomon par exemple il est clair que
monsieur salomon et en responsabilité
tant sous le gouvernement précédent que
pendant la gestion de cette crise savait
depuis le début qu'il y avait un plein
dans la gestion des marques et des
thèses par exemple et pour autant il a
menti délibérément il a fait passer des
informations erronées auprès de la
population qui ont mis en danger les
gens et là qu'on ne vienne pas nous dire
que il n'y avait pas une volonté
intentionnelle le mensonge était
intentionnel donc j'espère que la
manière dont cette enquête va être menée
permettra d'établir jusqu'au bout toutes
les responsabilités sans que qui que ce
soit puisse se passer entre les mailles
et puis pour les responsables politiques
il ne faudrait non pas que le couvercle
remaniement ministériel soit l'occasion
de permettre à certains de s'échapper
ils devront être poursuivis jusqu'au
bout et la sanction politique devra
aussi être une sanction pénale pour cela
le moment venu des sites et jérôme
salomon le directeur général de la santé
et ça doit remonter jusqu'à qui hormis
hormis jérôme salomon ça doit remonter
jusqu'au plus haut sommet de l'état vous
entendez bien je note que je l ai dit
tout à l'heure le président de la
république pour l'instant ne peut pas
être atteint puisqu'il bénéficie d'une
immunité pénale
de la même manière les ministres pour
l'instant son protégé et pourtant ils
devront rendre des comptes
parce que celles et ceux qui par exemple
le 15 mars dernier ont maintenu alors
qu'ils avaient fermé l'ensemble des
lieux de wilaya qui ont maintenu le 1er
tour des municipales ont envoyé un
certain nombre de personnes se mettre en
danger et il a été avéré dans l'enquêté
qui a été menée que un certain nombre de
personnes qui ont été contaminées et
certaines en sont mortes
à l'occasion de ce premier tour des
élections municipales donc par exemple
sur cet objet la celle et ceux qui ont
décidé pour des raisons politiciennes d'
instrumentalisation politicienne des
élections municipales de maintenir le
scrutin devront rendre des comptes
de la même manière toutes celles et tous
ceux qui ont créé la la pénurie de
masques
la pénurie de test la pénurie
industrielle et qui ont préféré mentir
mentir sciemment en donnant de mauvaises
consignes aux françaises et aux français
pour ne pas avoir à justifier de leur
politique passée tout cela aussi devront
être traduits en justice
quelle que soit la temporalité
aujourd'hui ce sont les exécutants d'une
certaine façon
demain ça devra être les ministres
actuellement
en place et le chef de l'état devra lui
aussi au moment venu rendre des comptes
alors cette enquête préliminaire elle
pose aussi des interrogations parce
qu'elle ne concerne pas la gestion de la
crise dans les ehpad qu'en pensez vous
oui on voit que d'une certaine façon il
ya la volonté de regrouper les
différentes les différents taux plein
c'est ce que fait monsieur rémy ce
procureur de paris
est ce un souci d'homogénéisation est ce
que est ce justement pour pouvoir mieux
mettre le couvercle sur l'ensemble de
ses affaires et puis d'un autre côté il
ya un saucissonnage avec d'un côté les
ehpad de l'autre côté l'ensemble des d
autres d autres plaintes on se demande
un petit peu commencé à faire à la cent
sont traités l'important est que chacune
d'entre elles puisse aller aller au bout
et que lumière soit faite sur l'ensemble
des champs qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui
portés vous savez les gens réclament
justice
ils réclament avec toute la douleur qui
est la leur d'avoir dû affronter cette
crise pour certains d'avoir perdu des
proches et le on ne pourra pas se se
passer dans ce dans ce pays si l'on veut
reconstruire
et si l'on veut faire un pas en avant
démocratique d'aller au bout de
l'ensemble de ses profits de ces
procédures il ne faut pas que les passe
droits politiques
tant qu'on a l'habitude de les avoir
puisse imposer une fois encore je dis
cela en pensant notamment à la
commission denquête qui a été mise en
place par l'exécutif par monsieur macron
il ya tout juste quarante huit heures
alors qu'il ya des commandes et
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
donc on peut avoir pour laquelle on peut
avoir une confiance limitée en tout cas
c'est mon cas parce que je considère que
c'est encore de la justice de lens
reçoit
et puis il y à la démarche kessel a des
citoyens des associations des syndicats
pour une justice populaire pour qu'à un
moment donné la justice républicaine
puisse donner les réponses aux questions
qui sont posées et nous veillerons nous
et les autres à ce que ces questions est
au bout merci beaucoup françois cocq
cofondateur de l'association corona
victime essayiste d'avoir réagi donc
cette ouverture d'une enquête
préliminaire par le parquet de paris
cela concerne donc la gestion de la
crise sanitaire par les autorités